[Music]
I wanted to look at something kind of
really underneath it all because the 48
laws of power I'm looking at this these
games that people are playing in this
kind of court like atmosphere with all
these politics going on and the
strategies being used and all of that I
wanted to like dig underneath it and go
into the mind and the and the guts of
what makes a person powerful or
successful not just with money but just
in the sense of feeling like you're a
powerful person and I have a chance to
work with 50 cent he was a fan of the 48
laws a lot of rappers are I've met quite
a few who feel like they've used the
book to help them he was one of them we
met we feat we found we had a really
interesting rapport we felt very
comfortable with each other as if we had
known each other for many years and so
we did this book together but for me the
idea was here's somebody who comes from
the absolute bottom of America Southside
Queens in the crack era when a
african-american male is not supposed to
live past the age of 25 particularly one
who's dealing drugs and who's dealing
with all the violence not only did he
manage without a mother or father in his
life he never knew his father his mother
was murdered when he was 8 he not only
did he manage to be a hustler but he
managed to get out of the hustling
racket he managed to get into music but
he managed to survive that horrible
world of music with all the crap
political games that go on with him
within he not only survived but he was
able to become successful but he kept
building on it and building on it
it's a typical American rags to riches
story I wanted to know why what's
underneath it what was that quality that
maybe we could learn and in spending
time with him I felt like if I could
summarize it in one word it's that this
is a man who comes to life without fear
so it's not just fear of death or
bullets that's the obvious thing we're
talking about I'm talking about here's a
man who's not afraid of change for
instance if something happens where a
situation is new
he's lost a job he's been cut off this
record contract or something happening
he does
get upset or worried he's calm he deals
with it in a fearless manner he takes
risks but the risks are controlled but
he's not afraid of failing he's not
afraid of being criticized he's not
afraid of being different from other
people when I thought about that but
it's just how powerful you could be in
life if you'd are not afraid of the
things that happen to you you're able to
feel balanced and in control and make
decisions not based on exaggerating
risks etc but on reality I just thought
it was incredibly powerful way to be in
the world I could feel it myself
influenced by him and seeing myself
going forward and when I looked at all
the people I've studied in history
Napoleon Bonaparte Franklin Delano
Roosevelt Catherine the Great chase Ari
Borgia all of the thousands of people
have studied they all shared that
quality and it's like a it's a way of
being in the world when you're afraid
and fearful it's like your mind close
the aperture of your mind closes up to
this and you stop looking at the world
around you you want everything to be
comfortable and familiar in the same you
you stay in your house you watch the
same TV shows everything just the circle
closes up when you're not afraid and
we've experienced it all in our lives
when you suddenly you're in a new
country and you just don't you're
traveling and you you feel open your
mind is active and alive you become
creative everything changes this is the
key to feeling powerful but also to
being creative in the world so I wanted
to get underneath all of the other
things the power the seduction the
strategy and see that quality that lay
underneath it all
I don't want to get angry here because
it's not about you but I get so annoyed
with that argument about it being an 8
how could something like that be an 8
sure where are all individuals and
somebody because of who they are in
their DNA and their experiences are a
little more timid than other people but
nobody is born without fear we are all
born into this world screaming and
crying bloody mess we're terrified of
being away from our mother for a few
minutes we're afraid of the dark we're
afraid of dying we're afraid of being
being beaten up in school we're afraid
of failing there's not an individual on
this planet I don't care who you're
talking about
who hasn't felt a lot of fear what
differentiates people are those we find
who tend to deal more with fearful
situations and don't and understand that
it's it's hurting them in life if by
becoming fearful their their their
maiming themselves and they learn to
move past these fears that's what
separates people that's what separated
50 he he saw being on the streets if he
was afraid it was just gonna mess him up
people could read it off him he'd get
conservative it doesn't work it wouldn't
work and so he learned that he had to
teach himself to not be fear fearless
fearful in any circumstance in life
that's what the book is there for
certainly some people don't have as much
clay to work with or they're older and
they're and things are set but everybody
has the capacity to be more realistic
and realize that the reason they're
holding on to that bad job it's not
because they're being realistic or
prudent or being a good worker it's
because they're afraid they're afraid of
change they're afraid of leaving
something they're afraid of anything
unfamiliar it's fear when you understand
the fear then you can begin to move past
it so when I hear the people say it's
it's an aid you can't learn it I just
want to hit them in the head I don't
know